yeah I mean I think we're really the
crisis of 21st century culture is
standardization on one hand that's a
crisis precisely because it really flat
lines and just deadens the a lot of
amazing stuff but on the other hand as
the next couple years kick in you're
going to be seeing what i like to call
mass customization where everyone can
have you know their phone or their ipad
or whatever but they're going to pull it
into their own orbit in their own way
and they're pulling material that's out
there in the world as their own
vocabulary they didn't I didn't make
this phone you know but I've customized
and transformed it so I'm always
intrigued with saying that nothing stays
the same in this era in the 20th century
you know someone like you know Ford they
would say you know what you can have any
color car you want as long as it's black
you know they had the whole sense of
humor about the the production line all
making the Model T Ford car there was
the exact same machine rolling off the
leg now that was amazing because it was
high tech at that time but for the 21st
century where we could just retrofit and
reboot anything why stick to one thing I
mean just always transform and change
everything that's the DJ model as well
so by customizing and transforming it
adds new life to I think the way we
function right now when I say the way we
function i'm talking about going down
the street walking you know around
everyone has a little computer which is
essentially as a cell phone most people
i'm sorry you know there's a class
division here but even in economically
you know low-income and so on most
people have some kind of communications
device and I think it's transformed the
way the world works right now and this
is just the beginning so within the next
five to seven years or be seeing
probably a massive revolution and
getting rid of sameness and just having
this wildly creative and inventive arrow
you